>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Elmer Eusman: Good morning.
My name is Elmer Eusman,
I'm the chief conservative
here at the library.
And I wanted to welcome you
all to the 80th TOPS lecture,
topics and preservation
series, 80, I can't believe it.
Before I introduce Andrew who
will introduce our speaker,
I just wanted to announce that our
next TOPS lecture will be Monday,
September 12, and it will deal
with using computer tomography
to digitally unroll
and render the text
from a circa 1500 BCE
Elephantine island roll of papyrus.
So, for those of you
who are interested
in that, Monday, September 12.
Here to introduce our
speaker is Andrew Robb.
Andrew is the Head of Special
Format Conservation Section and in
that role, in charge
of the conservation
of the library's photographic
material.
Andrew.
>> Andrew Rob: Thank you, Elmer.
A warm welcome to our
speaker, Rachel Wetzel.
She's very familiar to us here.
In 2003, she was a summer
graduate fellow with us,
the conservation division and
it's wonderful to have her return
to give this lecture on her
work concerning the conservation
of early daguerreotypes, a topic
of great relevance particularly
to us in-- on our collection as
well as to many others who are here
in the audience and over the web.
It would be great to have this on
our website archive so that people
in the future will be able
to access this presentation.
Rachelle has been on the staff of
the Conservation Center for Art
and Historic Artifacts since 2007
where she's a conservative
photographs.
In addition to her
work as a conservator,
she also conducts surveys,
teaches photography-related courses
and workshops at graduate schools,
libraries, archives and museums.
And she's been an officer of
the photographic materials group
at the American Institute
for Conservation.
Her educational background
includes post graduate work
at the advanced residency
program in photograph conservation
at the George Eastman, now museum,
and the Image Permanence Institute,
a master's degree in
art conservation
from the State University of
New York Buffalo State College.
And a bachelor-- excuse
me, a bachelor's degree
from the University of Pittsburgh.
Besides her work with
daguerreotypes,
she's published several papers
on optical brightening agents
and [inaudible] photographic
materials.
So, her research interests are broad
and we welcome that
in our small field.
Her presentation this morning
is conservation science
in the daguerreotype preserving our
earliest photographic treasures.
Rachel.
[ Applause ]
>> Rachel K. Wetzel: Thank you.
Can you all hear me OK?
Great. Good morning, I'm very
happy to be back here at LC.
This is, you know, sort of
where I started my career
in photo conservation so, it's nice
to come back and go back to all
of you, all of the things
I've been working on recently.
In today's lecture, I'll be taking
you down in the historic path
of early photography,
how that was invented,
how it arrived here in America.
We will be exploring a little
bit of the improvements made
to the daguerreotypes process.
I would explain exactly
what a daguerreotype is.
And then, from all of those bits of
information, I'll be able to explain
to you a little better
about why this project
with early daguerreotypes and
preservation is very important
and necessary for the field
of photo conservation.
Oops.
So, try to imagine a time
before there was photography
which right now is pretty hard
to do since we all have cameras
on our phones and it's
extremely common place and easy
to take a photograph but you
just go back another century
to the 19th century and the earlier
part of it, there was no photography
and people could not see a rendering
of themselves or a portrait
of a beautiful landscape outside.
But the 19th century, the early
19th century is very centered
around inventing some sort
of photographic process.
And it began pretty early in the
19th century, there were a lot
of people experimenting
and trying to do this
but with not much great success.
So-- And these people
were scientist,
they were some curious thinkers.
And they were all trying to find
a way to sort of capture an image
and maintain it on
some sort of substrate.
Only some of them would gain
some success in doing so,
but they would-- Silver would
keep printing out and printing
out until they had a dark piece
of paper or a dark metal plate.
But on January 17th 1839, one person
found a way to sustain an image
on a metal plate thus giving
rise to the birth of photography.
And that man was Louis-Jacques-Mandé
Daguerre, he was a Parisian artist
and he's credited for inventing
the first photographic process.
And this is a daguerreotype
that was taken of him.
So, Daguerre was a painter, he
wasn't a scientist like a lot
of the other people tinkering
around with inventing photographs.
He actually in 19th century ran
a very successful diorama studio
in Paris.
And the diorama was sort
of 19th century theatre.
These are the predecessor
to motion picture film.
And it was a room that utilized
several trompe-l'oeil style
landscape paintings.
They were illuminated in various
ways that allowed one painting
to change in scenery form light
to dark making a very
dramatic effect on one image.
So, the diorama provided a lot
of entertainment for Parisians
in the early 19th century.
But to make these very large
scale paintings for the diorama,
Daguerre utilized this piece of
equipment called the camera obscura
to project his sketches
on a large scale term.
And it was with this particular
apparatus that he started to play
around with inventing with
what we now call photography.
So, I suppose you can say
Daguerre was sort of a master
or manipulating light
in an artistic effect.
So, Daguerre's process quite
aptly named after himself
as many 19th century inventors would
probably call their photographic
process something that
included their name,
was the sensitized silver plate
that utilized a long exposure
to produce a faint image
on a mirror surface.
But at last, the, you know, this
landscape that you could see
in front of you could be contained
on this delicate piece of silver.
Proud of his amazing accomplishment,
the daguerreotype was presented
in front of the French
Academy of Sciences in 1983
and it wowed the Parisian community.
Never before had we
seen a photograph.
But Daguerre wasn't the only person,
as I mentioned, there were a lot
of people trying to
experiment to make a photograph.
But one other person that was
sort of successful and was working
at the same as Daguerre was
a guy named Nicéphore Niépce.
And Niépce a few hours
away from Daguerre
and he was inventing this
process called the heliograph,
which utilize the action of light
to harden an area of material
on a metal plate to
produce an image.
Niépce set up his camera on
the window of his country home
and in 1826, he captured this image
on the right, and it was the view
of Le Gras, his country home,
and what we now know today
to be the oldest photograph
in existence.
And this photograph is currently
housed at the Harry Ransom Center
at the University of
Texas in Austin.
This particular image on
the right is what you see
if you Google search the heliograph
process or Niépce's photograph.
And it's usually reproduced in
a very contrasty and greeny way
to make the image more visible.
But 19th century photography
was pretty crude,
and what it actually looks
like is on the right.
So, right now, we look at this
and we don't think it's
really that spectacular.
But in 1829, it was pretty
phenomenal that this could--
what he was looking out his window
to see what he was actually
capturing on this plate.
So, it's very rare and special
and very sensitive and delicate
and might not look like the best
composition of the photograph
or the best shape of the photograph
but this photograph
is very significant
to the history of photography.
So, prior to 1839, Daguerre
and Niépce were both
working independently
and they were both
happen to be buying lenses
for their camera obscuras from a man
named Charles Chevalier in Paris.
And Chevalier knew of both men's
work and he suggested to one
of the men that they
perhaps collaborate
on trying to make a photograph.
And Daguerre was very interested
in meeting with Niépce and trying
to collaborate and maybe helping
one another to sort of solve a lot
of issues they were having with
the printing out of the silver
and not being able to
contain the image permanently.
Bu t Niépce did not want
to meet with Daguerre.
But Daguerre was very persistent and
he wrote several letters to Niépce
over the course of a number of years
and eventually, the two men agreed
to meet and reveal
their particular--
the heliograph and the
daguerreotype to one another.
But unfortunately,
Niépce passed away in 1833
so he never saw the official
birth of photography in 1839.
So, there was one more man in
this long trail of the birth
of photography that is worth
mentioning here and that man is--
an English man named
Sir John Herschel.
Herschel discovered that sodium
thiosulfate is the silver halide
solvent in 1819 and eventually,
this became the key element
to stopping the silver reaction
when making a photograph.
So this compound, sodium
thiosulface if you've done any black
and white photography, we call fixer
today, and it's the one material
in the process of development
that will stop the
silver halide reactions
and make the silver
permanent for stable--
and stabilize the image
for permanency.
So, it was Herschel's discovery
that helped Daguerre stabilize
his daguerreotype process
and make his image permanent.
So, kind of without Herschel's
discovery Daguerre wouldn't be able
to do his.
So there's a lot of people
contributing to the invention
of photography at that time.
And just shortly after Daguerre
presented his process at the Academy
of Sciences in Paris, Herschel was
presenting his discovery of fixer
at the Royal Society of London.
So, everything was sort
of happening in 1839 based
around this daguerreotype invention.
So, Daguerre's process
created quite a bit
of enthusiasm upon its
announcement in 1839,
and though he kept his secret-- his
formula secret, everybody wanted
to make one of these
daguerreotypes, but nobody knew how.
So, he was trying to coin
the market, rightfully so,
he needed to make a living
and he invented this process.
So, he was trying to
sell subscriptions
to how people buy his daguerreotype
plates but it just wasn't
as successful as he would
have liked it to have been.
And Daguerre finally agreed
with the French government to--
in exchange for a finance--
to be financed or have a salary
from the French government,
he had to release his
daguerreotype formula.
And this happened in August.
So, a number of months later
after it was officially announced
and then daguerreotype mania began.
So, Daguerre's formula was quickly
translated into several languages
and distributed worldwide.
It made its way to the United States
and is shipped in September of 1839.
And, however, while the
daguerreotype formula traversed the
ocean, the actual idea of the
daguerreotype existing had arrived
in America long before that.
So, in January of 1839 when Daguerre
was making his announcement,
there was also a man
from the United States,
from New York named Samuel Morse.
And Morse was over in Paris
presenting his new invention,
the electromagnetic telegraph and
you may know Morse from Morse code,
he's quite-- he's also
made photographs
but he also invented
quite a few things.
And Morse thought his invention was
going to be the hot topic in Paris,
but unfortunately, all anybody could
talk about was the daguerreotype.
So, being a curious-minded person,
Morse needed to know what this
daguerreotype was and he went
to Daguerre studio and he had a look
at it and he was just fascinated.
So, he wrote letters
back to United States
to his colleagues telling them
about this fantastic invention
that was happening in Paris.
So, there was a lot of hype
about the daguerreotype
before we even knew how
to make one here in
the United States.
So, when the formula
arrived in September of 1839,
the first man in Philadelphia
to attempt
to make a photograph was
this man, Joseph Saxton.
So keep in mind, this
is early photography.
In 1839, you couldn't
just go to a store
and buy all your photographic
equipment.
You couldn't just buy
a camera and a plate.
You had to procure all of these
materials and chemicals yourself
and you had to figure out how
to construct your camera and how
to measure out all the chemicals.
It wasn't like you
bought Kodak fixer.
So, Saxton, according to
the notes made his camera
out of a cigar box and
a ground glass lens.
Saxton needed a metal plate to
make his daguerreotype and this--
on the right for you is the
daguerreotype that he made
from his window at the US Mint.
But to make this plate,
he went down the street
to a metal working lighting shop
called Cornelius and Company,
where he requested silver
coated copper plates.
And that man who made his silver
coated copper plates was a man named
Robert Cornelius.
So, Robert Cornelius, and this
is a later photograph of him,
not only was a metal worker
but he had an interest
and a background in chemistry.
When learning of Saxton's
experimentation
with the daguerreotype, he
too, decided to give it a try.
So, Cornelius set up
his daguerreotype camera
in the back alley of his
family's company shop
and he placed is sensitized plate
and the camera and he stood in front
of the camera lens for quite a long
time to take what we know today
to be the very first self portrait.
So, some of the facts you should
know about the daguerreotype process
in 1839, as I mentioned, the
exposure times were quite long.
So, they could range anywhere from
three to 15 minutes and upwards
to half an hour depending on
the light conditions outside
and the brightness of the sun.
The long exposures prohibited
the capturing of motion.
So, if you see most of the early
1839 daguerreotypes are landscapes
and then if you look at them,
you won't see any people on them.
So, Daguerre took a lot
of street scenes of Paris
and there aren't any people in
most of those daguerreotypes.
And the reason for this is that
because the exposure time could be
up to half an hour, if anybody was
just walking by on the streets,
they wouldn't get captured
in the image.
You'd have to stand still
in the frame of the camera
for a significant amount of
time to procure a daguerreotype.
So, a lot of people thought that
Daguerre woke up really early
in the morning when the
streets weren't busy
and took these photographs,
but actually,
it's just the long exposure time
that prohibits the
motion being captured.
So, Robert Cornelius, after
he made his self portrait,
he decides to collaborate
with another chemist
from the University of Pennsylvania.
And if you've been to Philadelphia,
you know Philadelphia Center City
is quite small and compact and all
of these places were located sort
of within a block or
two of one another.
So, here's University of
Pennsylvania, US Mint,
Cornelius's family business,
the Franklin Institute,
the American Philosophical
Science Society.
And all these places I'm going to be
talking about are within, you know,
five minutes walk of one another.
So, at the University
of Pennsylvania,
there was a man named Paul Beck
Goddard and he was a chemist
and he had an interest
in making daguerreotypes.
And on the right here is a
landscape daguerreotype that he made
from his window at the University of
Pennsylvania in 1839 and it belongs
to the Franklin Institute.
So because Cornelius had taken
the self portrait using the
daguerreotype process which as I
mentioned had a very long exposure
time, the two men saw
this marketability
and the daguerreotype
for portraiture.
However, because the
exposures were so long,
it really made this
process unsuitable
for rendering the likeness
of a human image.
As the sitter would have
to sit perfectly still
for a very long time, which
try to sit in your seat
for the next two minutes and
not move, it's really difficult.
So, together, they experimented
with the sensitization
step of the process.
And in order to reduce the
exposure time of the plate,
they replaced one halogen, which
in Daguerre's original formula was
iodine with bromine.
And first experiment show
that bromine had a little
bit of hazing on the plate.
So, they were doing some
experiment with iodine
and bromine and then iodine again.
But with these experiments
and changing out the halogen,
they were able to make the exposure
time of the plate, they could cut it
in half, which made still
a long time to sit still
but way less excruciating
than, you know, 15 minutes.
So, just a little side
note of interest, bromine,
the element wasn't even discovered
until 1826 and we're talking
about 1839 right now, so, this
is just a little over 10 years
after this element
is even discovered.
And legend has it that Cornelius and
Goddard bought up all the bromine
that they could possibly
get in the area.
So, the philosophical
society in Philadelphia
and the Franklin Institute
were the main two places
where you would present
new scientific discoveries.
So, Cornelius and Goddard presented
these two particular daguerreotypes
there at one of the annual meetings.
And the one on the left
the portrait of Goddard.
So, this one was made before
Cornelius's studio opened,
but it would make sense that
you would take a picture
of your partner.
So, in 1840, these were
presented with great praise
at the American Philosophical
Society to the scientific community.
So, Cornelius went on for the
next year making portraits
in his first studio at
8th and Lodge Alley.
So, if you're familiar
with Philadelphia, it's--
8th between Chestnut and Market.
And Lodge Alley no longer exists.
All of these images were made
on plates that Cornelius made
since he was a metal worker.
And all of these image are housed
in a very non-traditional
metal frame style
that Cornelius made himself.
And these three examples are
some of the variants you will see
from his handmade housing samples.
Additionally, on the verse of all
of the Cornelius daguerreotypes,
you will see a paper backing
that contains a paper label
with the Cornelius studio name.
So, this was sort of the way
that an artist would sign
his painting, daguerreotype.
This is the way to sign
your daguerreotype.
So, the following year in 1841,
Cornelius set up a
second portrait studio.
And this one was on a second floor
and it had better natural lighting.
And at this point, Cornelius had
really kind of perfected his craft
of portraiture in the short time
that he was making daguerreotypes.
And he was able to reflect the sun
from his window on to his sitters
in a way that made it much
more painterly and scholarly.
And with this area or
portraiture, he also put his images
into traditional leather cases
that we use here in America.
So, daguerreotypes in Paris
were put into his glass housing
that were called passepartout that
contain the reversed painted glass.
But in America, we traditionally
used little leather-embossed cases.
But while you can't see the
Cornelius paper label on these,
he did emboss his brass
mass with his name
and his studio address on them.
So, you'll know which
ones are Cornelius's.
Cornelius also-- He
retired in-- from--
he had a studio from
1840, he closed in 1843.
There's not a lot of records left
behind or notes from his studio.
There aren't list of people
he took his-- were sitters.
So, all that's left there are
the artifacts of his labor.
So we know that Cornelius's
family was
in the laying [phonetic] business
and the gas plants were coming
very popular at this time.
So, whether he went back to
work in his family's company
out of necessity or he just grew
tired of making daguerreotypes,
I'm not really sure of the later.
It seems feasible but
this is what you will read
in the historic literature.
But he closed off his shop in
1843 and he did make a handful
of daguerreotypes post his
"retirement" up until 1847.
So, as I mentioned, he didn't
leave behind any logbooks,
we don't have records
of his studio but his--
the portraits that he left behind
are really quite remarkable.
And his first studio portraits
were very straight on,
straightforward images
and bust from the waist up
and they were very
nice and very skilled.
But by the time he made
it to his second studio,
I think he really perfected
his angles of his sitters
and his portraits became
pretty phenomenal.
And on the-- This is a comparison,
on the left is the first studio
and the right is the second studio.
And it's not just me thing
that I think Robert Cornelius's
portraits were pretty great,
Daguerre himself found
Cornelius's portraits
to be pretty phenomenal as well.
So, and he-- Daguerre sent
a mammoth-like daguerreotype
of Notre Dame to the Franklin
Institute in this note on the back
of the daguerreotype indicates
that Daguerre was sending this
particular daguerreotype to America
in exchange for portraits
made by Robert Cornelius.
So, to have the inventor
of the process request your
daguerreotype is probably the
highest honor you could have.
However, all that remains
in the legend
of Robert Cornelius can only
be deduced in the series
of beautiful portraits he
captured between 1839 and 1847,
in the earliest era of
photography in the United States.
And as of now, there
are fewer than 50
of his daguerreotypes
known to have survived.
And these are just
some of the locations
that hold Cornelius's
daguerreotypes.
So, for those who don't know
what a daguerreotype is,
I will give you a little
explanation.
So, it's a highly polished
silver plate,
it's most commonly a thin layer
of silver coated over copper
that has been smoothed
to a mirror finish.
And the process of making a
daguerreotype goes as follows.
Step number one is to prepare
your silver coated copper plate
by clipping the corners.
This helps you with polishing.
And the second step is to
polish your silver plate
to a mirror finish.
This polishing takes
many, many hours to do
to get the daguerreotype
smooth and shiny.
And you will often see when you
look at a daguerreotype and hold it
on a certain angle that you can see
the polished marks and you can tell
which direction they go,
up or down or side to side.
Number three is to subject the
plate to vapors of halogen.
And as I mentioned before Daguerre's
original formula used iodine
and then later, it's what we call
double sensitization, so it's iodine
and bromine or a combination
of the two.
And that made the plate
light sensitive.
At that point, you would place your
plate in the daguerreotype camera
to take the exposure
and after that was done,
you would develop your images
in the fumes or mercury.
And to stop that silver
reaction, this is where that fixer
or sodium thiosulfate comes in.
And then, the next step in
this timeline occurs post 1841
and doesn't apply to the
earliest daguerreotypes
but there was a step called gilding
and this was the coating
of gold chloride.
And the gold chloride would be
put on the surface of the plate,
and I'll explain this a little
bit more in detail later
but in the earliest of
Cornelius's experiments, this step--
sorry, step did not exist.
And then the final step for all
daguerreotypes was to seal them
up because this is a highly
polished piece of silver
and it tarnished quite readily.
So, they've figured out pretty
quickly that they needed to seal it
in some sort of environment
that would protect it
from the atmosphere.
So, this is what the
finished product
of a daguerreotype looks like.
And it's a little bit hard
to see when you pick one
up because it's a mirror
and it's reflective.
So, at a certain angle, with a dark
material blocking the reflectance,
you can actually see
the daguerreotype image.
So, you could see the woman here.
And if you tilt it a little
bit, the image become--
appears more like a negative.
So, the silver changes
and it makes the parts
that stick out sort of recess.
And if you tilt it even more,
it just becomes a solid mirror.
So, you can see the reflectance
of this newspaper in the image.
So, as I mentioned before
daguerreotypes needed to be sealed
to slow down the sulfur and other
pollutants in the atmosphere to--
from tarnishing the silver plate.
And I mentioned that the French
used the reverse painted glass
passepartout and in America, we
use these embossed leather cases
that were made into standard sizes.
So, the daguerreotype package would
generally include Daguerre brass mat
that was placed directly on
top of the daguerreotype plate.
Over that, a shade of glass would be
put on top and around the perimeter
of this package, it was usually
sealed off with some kind
of paper tape with an adhesive.
And then, that tape would be
covered by a brass preserver
to cover the seal around
the daguerreotype package.
And the entire daguerreotype
package will be fitted into one
of these custom leather
cases and the leather,
it was usually embossed leather
and there was on the lid side,
there's a material that
help with the reflectance
and viewing of the daguerreotype.
So, in this particular one I have
on the screen, it's a solid piece
of silk and that's sort of
the earlier style of case
but later they became dark
colored embossed velvet.
So, in addition of
providing the daguerreotype
with a special handheld housing,
the cases and passepartout served
as protection from the harmful
gases in the environment.
Being pure of silver, the
plates had a tendency to tarnish
if they were left bare
and open to the elements.
So, on the left is an example
where the tarnish is quite heavy
and the pattern that forms
corresponds to the shape usually
of the brass mat that
sat on top of it.
Color interference rings would cover
the surface obscuring the image
from the outside in.
Daguerreotypes are also susceptible
to abrasion and that layer
of silver that's coated on
the copper is extremely thin.
So, if you touched it with your
finger or some other material,
you could easily disrupt the silver
and the copper beneath
could be exposed.
And if you have moisture
in the environment,
then copper corrosion can form
and little mushroom like areas
of copper byproducts can protrude
to the surface of the daguerreotype
and you can see that
in the daguerreotype
on the right, the sitter
on the left.
One other common problem
that daguerreotypes have are
deterioration over time is
that the glass that's placed
on top of them also corrodes.
And the glass will ooze out
silica and other byproducts
of the glass production and
so it's the lag type forms--
formations that dangle
down from the glass
on to the copper-- the
daguerreotype plate.
So, the oldest of the
daguerreotypes--
daguerreotype plates
are at the greatest risk
to these naturally occurring
deterioration issues.
And this is the rubber
in Cornelius's self portrait that's
owned by the Library of Congress.
And you can see on the
right, in this detail
that the perimeter
tarnishing is quite heavy.
And these two Cornelius plates
that is shown before exhibit,
a white haze around their perimeters
and these are the byproducts
of historic cleaning.
These two daguerreotypes are owned
by the American Philosophical
Society and they were brought to me
at the conservation center
by Philosophical Society's
conserver Anne Downey.
And Anne was concerned that when
she began working at her job
that she had seen these and then
she'd look at them really recently
and she thought they had changed and
had more tarnished and more hazing
than she remembered when
she started at her job.
And she asked me if there was
anything I could do to treat them.
And I knew they're Robert Cornelius
daguerreotypes and looking at them
that they were some of the earliest
daguerreotypes made here in America
and I told her there was no
way I can just do a treatment
on these two daguerreotypes.
There has to be a huge
research project.
We don't have a lot of information
about these early materials.
So, my first step was to telephone
my colleague Adrienne Lundgren here
at the Library of Congress because I
know she really loves daguerreotypes
as much as I do and I also knew
that there was a large collection
of Robert Cornelius's holdings here.
So, together we talked about,
you know, I explained my problem
and she was telling me that she had
the self portrait and it was not
in very good shape either.
So, together we decided we needed to
collaborate on a research project.
So, several issues that post
challenges for conservators
with these materials, their--
the primary issue is that the
daguerreotypes that were made
between 1839 and 1841
were not gilded,
and I mentioned this gold
chloride stuff in the production
of the daguerreotype earlier.
So, the gilding added a protective
layer to the silver image particles,
it also helped make the image a
little more adorable and stable
than their ungilded counterparts.
The gilding also helped
visually with some
of the contrast of the image.
So, when you compare ungilded n
the left versus the gilded image
on the right, you can see the
ungilded image is a little
bit flatter.
But both images, all daguerreotypes
are incredibly fragile materials,
it just happens that the ungilded
daguerreotype are even more prone
to abrasion, which limits a lot
of the treatment options we have
currently for gilded daguerreotypes,
which comprises most of
the body of daguerreotypes.
So, the tarnishing of the
silver is the second issue
that we need to consider.
So, tarnish was a problem from
the beginning of production
of daguerreotypes as I
mentioned and so much
so by 1850 it was very common
that tarnishes already occurred
on daguerreotype plates.
And people in the 19th century
were cleaning daguerreotypes
with solution of potassium cyanide.
So with this cleaner, it
might work miracles at time--
at that time and it might have made
the plate pretty shiny and new.
But today, 177 years later residual
amounts of cyanide can be found
on the surfaces of
daguerreotype plate.
And you can see deterioration
that was caused by the cyanide.
So, cyanide can be found
on the daguerreotype
plate for many reasons.
Sometimes, it was used in the
production of the plate cladding.
Sometimes it was used
in the development.
And sometimes, it could just be
caused from historic cleaning.
In this side-by-side
comparison on the left,
you can see the corresponding
tarnish on the silver plate
with the pattern of the fluorescent
cyanide in the image next to it.
So, the image on the right is an
image under ultraviolet light,
under UVC and it shows all of that
fluorescence caused by the cyanide.
You can't see that
with the visible eye.
But you can look in the bottom
right corner and see sort
of a corresponding
pattern of deterioration
and that is pretty aligned
with the cyanide on the plate.
And then later in the 20th century,
in the 1950s we had a new compound
for clearing silver called thiourea.
And thiourea started to be
used to clean daguerreotypes.
And again, this was another compound
that you'd clean your daguerreotype
with, probably looked pretty great
at the time, but now, you know, 40,
50 years later, we are seeing a lot
of white residues and hazing on
daguerreotypes that were cleaned
with thiourea and likely
not washed very well
or over cleaned with thiourea.
And cleaning of daguerreotypes
with this solution was very popular
so much so that it was published
in a Time Life book series,
it was in many photographic
magazines.
So, a lot of people were
cleaning their daguerreotypes
and not necessarily conservators
or scientists, people just--
who had daguerreotypes read
about this new cleaning method
and we're trying it out.
So, this will play a big
part a little bit later
on what we're dealing with
today as conservators.
So just to give you an idea,
this is the daguerreotypes
of Paul Beck Goddard that APS has.
And this one was cleaned in
thiourea in the late 1970s.
And I know this for a fact
because there's a note on the back
of this daguerreotype indicating so.
So, well, I'm sure it looked pretty
good at the time it was cleaned.
Now, it doesn't look
so great 40 years later
and you could see there's a
white haze around the perimeter
so that area would have been
the heaviest area of tarnish.
So that thiourea has left a
really undesirable white hazing
on the heaviest part of the silver,
but there's also a haze overall.
And then another result of these
historic cleanings is what we
call measles.
So, on the right if
you look at that image,
same image in specular
illumination and you can see all
of these brown tiny dots
on the surface of the plate
and those are all residual
byproducts of the historic cleaning.
And here's the detail
under the microscope.
You can see, this is the surface
of the plate and there are a bunch
of abrasions and scratches.
And I'm not 100% certain
that these were products
of Cornelius's working style
or products of, you know,
a brush being applied to
this daguerreotype plate
when it was cleaned in the 1970s.
But just to give you an indication
of how easily these can be abraded,
you can see it really
makes a bunch of scratches
on the surface which
cannot be removed.
But to make matters worse for
this poor portrait of Goddard,
I looked at it under
ultraviolet illumination
and this one also has
cyanide all over the surface.
So, it's likely-- it could
have been cleaned twice
with two different cleaners,
which isn't an uncommon phenomenon
for early daguerreotypes.
And the portrait of
Pierre Etienne DuPonceau,
he survived a little
bit better than Goddard,
so his plate on specular
illumination just shows a little bit
of the hazing.
But what I wanted to point out here
is there are some distinct little
polish marks on the plate, which
we looked at and saw on a lot
of early daguerreotype plates.
And we're thinking that maybe
at first these were significant
in particular to Robert Cornelius
but we're finding on a lot
of these old plates
from 1839 that were hand
on that these little tiny hash
marks in them that these could be,
you know, a good indicator for
authenticity of material later.
So, conservation treatment
of the daguerreotype is rather a
controversial topic in the field
of photograph conservation.
And while there have been
people restoring art works
since there have been art around,
the field of photograph
conservation is really quite new.
So, it formed its infancy in the
1970s at the George Eastman--
what was George Eastman house,
which is now George Eastman
museum in Rochester, New York.
And a group of caretakers
of photographs were
developing treatment protocols
and preservation standards
for daguerreotypes.
And these people eventually served
as the folks who were mentors
and teachers in the art conservation
programs that developed here
in the United States in the 1970s.
And it was with all of
these people's efforts
that photograph conservation was
established as a career path.
So, in reaction to all
of these well-intentioned
but rampant cleaning of
daguerreotypes that sometimes ended
in destruction or undesirable
effects for the daguerreotypes,
these folks put a moratorium on
cleaning daguerreotypes in the 1980s
until they could further
study this issue.
Nowadays, conservators are washing
daguerreotypes with various methods
that we have deemed to
be safe and ethical.
Though there are some photograph
conservators to this day
who still will not
wash a daguerreotype.
But still we need to intervene
with some aqueous methods sometimes
on daguerreotypes and we need
to understand their long term
effects including the modern day
techniques that we use.
But right now in our field, we
really don't have any protocols
for reducing or reversing effects
of the historic cleaners
on daguerreotypes.
We don't have any information on
cleaning ungilded daguerreotypes
and we're not even 100% certain of
the longevity of our current methods
of cleaning gilded daguerreotype.
Leaving us with the question--
I forgot to show you this.
This is before and
after cyanide cleaning.
So, this is just a quick path
to show what can be removed
with our modern day methods.
So, we're left with
this question of,
can a conservator wash
these early daguerreotypes
that have been suffering the effects
of multiple historic cleanings
over the last 177 years?
So, of course, that-- the question
is not a very simple answer.
And as conservators, we can't
just experiment with these rare
and early daguerreotypes as we have
to follow strict codes of ethics
in our field to do no harm.
And in order to reverse
what we've already done,
what's already been done, a thorough
conservation science-based research
project needs to be
conducted before any method
of treatment could even be
considered to be attempted.
So, we need to understand the
effects of these historic cleaners,
we also need to know the effects
of our current cleaners and we need
to understand how to reverse
these damaging effects in a way
that it will be safe and
preserve these daguerreotypes
for the long haul.
So, a study of such
would include mockups
that closely replicate
the early working methods
of the daguerreotypist that
were working in 1839 in order
to see what approach works best.
Then and only then
when positive outcomes
and safe procedures can be devised
from these experiments
could we even think
about performing conservation
treatment on these early rare
and valuable daguerreotypes.
So, with a project
of this magnitude,
a team of experts is needed.
So, as I mentioned before, some
people are in the audience.
Adrienne Lundgren is on the
left, she's my colleague
that I initially contacted.
And so, Adrienne and I on the right,
decided with her supervisor Angie
Rob [assumed spelling] who's also
here at Library of
Congress to develop a team
of people to work on this project.
So, we need a scientist and
the person that we chose
for the project is Edward
Vicenzi who's at Smithsonian MCI.
And he's worked with
daguerreotype projects in the past
with a man named Mike Robinson
who's in the bottom left.
And Mike Robinson is a
modern day daguerreotypist.
So, Mike is the person who is
making all of our test samples.
But together, they have worked
on some research with Southworth
and Hawes that has been
recently published.
So, they were likely two
candidates for working
on a daguerreotype project
with Adrienne and I.
We also-- Part of the research team,
we're looking at the curatorial
aspects of daguerreotypes
and early daguerreotypists and
so we need a curatorial team
and the people that we have
are Beverly Brannan from--
she's a curator here of
photography at Library of Congress.
Will Stapp who was former curator
at the American Portrait Gallery
and he is the author of the one
and only book on Robert Cornelius.
And then recently joining our team
is Sarah Weatherwax who's curator
of Prints and Photographs at the
Library Company in Philadelphia
who holds a lot of daguerreotypes
by Robert Cornelius as well.
So, these people will be helping us
with a grant project that's been--
that's application
process is current.
Hoping to get the grant to form
a database of focusing primarily
on the-- all of the works of Robert
Cornelius but also including other
of Cornelius's contemporaries from
1839 to 1841 that we're working
on this ungilded era
of daguerreotyping.
So those, we plan to look at every
one of those and study their--
them from a science-base,
conservation-base
and a curatorial-base aspect and
make a database that would be useful
for collecting information.
How these early daguerreotypes,
you know, how they looked,
how they were constructed, how
they survived over the years.
What kind of environments they
were in that will be useful
for later phases of our studies.
So, later investigations of this
project beyond what we're looking
at now of just how the
historic cleaners affect these
daguerreotype plates.
We'll include studies on protocols,
how to reduce the damaging effects
of these historic cleaners and
also how to develop proper storage
and housing on recommendations for
daguerreotypes so that, you know,
they don't tarnish in the future.
It is of my personal
opinion that doing nothing
with these daguerreotypes
and just letting them tarnish
until they're completely
black is, you know,
kind of just as doing a disservice
to the daguerreotypes as, you know,
intervening with historic
cleaners or,
you know, trying out new methods.
I mean, we need to figure out a
proper way to do it before we try it
but I think we can't just let
them deteriorate into nothing.
So, I personally would like
to see this team and pull all
of our collaborative resources,
our expertise and our knowledge,
our understanding of daguerreotypes
together to preserve all these rare
and valuable irreplaceable
daguerreotypes
that are the earliest
photographic treasures
that we have here in
the United States.
And I would like to see them exist
in another 177 years and beyond.
So, here's just an example
of some of the works
of Robert Cornelius starting at the
upper left with his self portrait
and moving to the bottom right
through the years you can see
how his photography progressed.
And this is a time lapse video so,
those of you who are not familiar
with conservation, we
don't work really fast.
So, until we can do
all this research,
we will just seal these
daguerreotypes back up in a way
that we know to be best using
our standard procedures and wait
for the outcome of the research.
And hopefully, I will be
back along with my colleague,
Adrienne Lundgren, in a few years
presenting some positive results
from our collective research.
So, photography is a fragile
miracle of science and I hope that,
you know, it can leave
and we can leave--
hope it leave an indelible
mark on generations to come.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
Any questions?
>> I have a question.
>> Rachel K. Wetzel: Sure.
>> Really great topic and
very detailed in a good way.
Assuming some people who are
watching this has daguerreotypes
at home or in their
family collections
and then perhaps they may want
to donate them to the Library
of Congress in the future, it may
happen, what would you suggest
to them that they do
or not do to these?
Like, I'm guessing, let's
say, can we wash them?
Control the humidity?
What else would you say?
>> Rachel K. Wetzel: Sure.
So, the question for
the web audience was,
if you have daguerreotypes
at home, what should you
or should you not do while you
have them in your possession.
So, unfortunately daguerreotypes
are these things that people are
so curious about and they
love to pull out of the cases
and open them up, but really,
you should just leave them alone.
People always think that there's
going to be a note or a patch
of hair underneath the
daguerreotype and the case.
But even just the action of
pulling the daguerreotypes
out of the case can cause
damage to the daguerreotype.
And if you're taking off
brass mats and preservers
and disrupting things,
you're just opening things
up to the environment.
So, they were putting
these cases for a reason.
So, the daguerreotypes, you should
keep them like most photographs.
Not in your basement
and not in your attic.
Daguerreotypes are usually
in the American style case,
so they are sort of protected
from light themselves.
But you, you know, might want to
keep them in an area of your house
that isn't near the light or
is, you know, isn't exposed.
It's not going to get exposed
through the leather case.
But, in general, for
photographs, we tell people
to keep them in the dark.
But yeah, I think, just--
like leaving them alone is
probably the best thing you can do,
if that helps.
>> Can you add storage to that?
Storage conditions like what kind
of box we should put them in?
>> Rachel K. Wetzel: OK.
The question is in what kind
of boxes should you
put daguerreotypes in?
Any kind of archival
base box that is made
from alkaline non-reactive materials
is fine to put the daguerreotype in.
You can buy these readily
from archival suppliers.
You can make your own
four flat boxes.
There are instructions you can
find on the internet to do this.
But just anything that's
non-reactive.
Yes?
>> Where are you in your research?
>> Rachel K. Wetzel: The question
is where are we in the research.
So, I'm actually here this week,
we're here on the research.
We have already made the plate,
so we're just in the process
of doing preliminary
testing, ACM testing.
So, it's pretty early on.
In the back.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
Sure. The question was about
how do we limit the exposure
of the ultraviolet illumination
when examining the photographs.
So, I just-- thankfully, for the
power of digital photography today,
it's-- you don't have to
expose it for very long.
So, really, in just
turning on the light
and then my photographers
clicking the camera
and a few seconds later,
we have an image.
So, it doesn't get that much
light exposure to the ultraviolet.
>> Just keeping it low.
>> Rachel K. Wetzel: Well, it had--
there's no like keeping it low,
it's just one setting of UVC but--
and a lot of people ask
me about light exposure
like scanning photographs, but
that tiny little light that you get
to take a photograph is
not going to be damaging.
It's a cumulative light that causes
the damage to the photographs.
I can't tell if that's
a question or not.
Any other questions?
In the back?
>> I just want to say thank
you for the presentation.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Rachel K. Wetzel: Oh great.
We have to stop by then.
Any other-- are there
web questions or-- Mary?
OK.
>> Mary: Well, yeah, I just
want to clarify, I'm sorry.
If you do treat a daguerreotype,
do you throw out the old case?
>> Rachel K. Wetzel:
So, the question is,
if I treated the daguerreotype,
do I throw out the old case?
And the answer is no, we
don't throw out anything.
Every once in a while a glass
is so deteriorated that we have
to replace it with another glass.
But even in that case, I
personally return the original glass
to the client and keep
the original materials
with the object including the fact
that I've removed paper tape seals,
I will take those paper
tape seals off,
line them with a good
quality Japanese paper
and put them back on
the daguerreotype.
So, yeah, I don't throw up anything
that is on the daguerreotype.
>> Could you just continue on
with that and talk a little bit
about attribution based on-- not
like how you would, say, the case
or all those things in the light
of attribution for [inaudible].
>> Rachel K. Wetzel: Yeah sure.
So, in a case of the Cornelius's,
Cornelius made very specific cases
and these are attributes
to his particular workings.
So, for example, the self portrait,
we do not have the original
case that it was in.
So, this is problematic.
So, this is another
reason why you don't want
to take your daguerreotypes apart.
Because some of these
materials are specific
to the photographer's
working style himself
and can give us valuable information
that helps determine what kind
of construction or working
methodology one conservator--
or I'm sorry, one photographer had.
And it will help us study a
broad collection of materials.
So, by, you know-- and it's a
pretty common practice in sort
of dealing industry to
take a daguerreotype
out of one case and
put it in another.
But even-- there are, you know,
daguerreotype photography
became very popular
and there were quite a few
people making portraits
by the, you know, 1850s.
But some of the earlier
things really need to remain
in these materials that they
were placed in originally
because they do provide a
lot of valuable information.
And so, we can also tell a
lot of why things deteriorate
in a certain way based on
the materials that they used.
So, if you switch out a case and
we don't have the original case,
we don't know how that
material reacted
with the photograph over a time.
Yes?
>> Let me ask you, do you
know at the time in the 1840,
'50s how expensive
it would have been
to take a portrait of daguerreotype?
>> Rachel K. Wetzel: OK.
The question is how expensive it was
to have your daguerreotype
portrait made.
As I mentioned, we don't have
any Robert Cornelius's notes,
but there's a lot of advertisements
from the early 19th century
from daguerreotype studios.
So, it was roughly $5 to have a
daguerreotype made, which was a lot
of money in 1830s, 1840s.
Any other questions?
>> What do you consider
to be appropriate housing
for loose plates?
>> Rachel K. Wetzel: The
question is what do I consider
to be appropriate housing
for loose plates?
Well, loose plates are
extremely problematic
because they're 100%
exposed to the environment.
So, there were famous
daguerreotypist plate
that were found in these
wooden boxes that they used
in the 19th century to store
their box-- their daguerreotypes.
But, you know, have
faired OK but in general,
we don't recommend any wood.
But I would definitely recommend
having a conservator seal
up your daguerreotype in
a very simple package just
so it isn't exposed
to the environment.
So, one-- in part of
this Cornelius project,
I have met with family
members of Robert Cornelius
who have some portraits
of family members.
And the one portrait that Al showed
to me, he handed me was a bare plate
and there was no image on it.
He just stuck it in my hand
and he was like, turn it over.
And I turned it over and
there's an etch on the back
that says portrait
by Robert Cornelius.
I'm like, why is this
in my bare hand?
So, you leave it out and
it tarnishes to, you know,
the images are 100% obscured.
So, you know, these plates,
particularly this one
really needed a housing.
So, conservator is the
way to go for that.
>> What was the wash bath
in the washing video?
>> Rachel K. Wetzel: The wash bath
in the washing video
was ammonium hydroxide
which is our current
treatment method,
so ammonium hydroxide
and de-ionized water.
Any other questions?
Well, thank you so much
for having me here.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.